so I know this may the Jack Bauer Power
Hour 24 is coming back well let's be
honest with ourselves we kind of already
have it now Metal Gear Solid 5 Ground
zeroes so Metal Gear Solid 5 Ground
zeroes is the prequel to the upcoming
Metal Gear Solid 5 the phantom pain you
play as big boss you go extract this
POWs from this one camp that's pretty
much Guantanamo Bay can you go and
extract another one you extract two POWs
in the end that's really Ground Zero so
when I first got done with it I was like
you rescue two people that's it 30 bucks
gone great it took me an hour and a half
to do because I you know you go around
you stealth kill people you get seen you
got to take them out you stab people in
the neck and [ __ ] but in the end if you
wanted to you could fly through this
demo in ten minutes that's the first
mission when you beat the ground zeroes
mission you unlock a few other missions
so it doesn't end there you get more
gameplay to do which is pretty much a
showcase for the gameplay you got you're
sneaking missions you got your
assassination missions you're sabotage
missions you got your action missions
you don't sneak around you just blow
[ __ ] up which adds a lot of replay value
I'm gonna personally go out there and
say ground zeroes was made from Metal
Gear Solid fans no one who's not a Metal
Gear Solid fans gonna go out there and
pay thirty bucks for a long demo but if
you're a longtime Metal Gear Solid fan
let's be honest with ourselves you have
paid more than 30 bucks for less of a
demo yeah you remember that [ __ ] zone
under the Ender's you got that for the
Metal Gear Solid 2 demo be honest with
yourself I did and I played the [ __ ] out
of the demo so I don't sweat it I'm like
well I've done more for less doesn't
matter but if we're looking at gameplay
the gameplay in this game is everything
I personally loved about the old Metal
Gear Solid's and everything I loved
about Peace Walker combined into one
feel like it's a segue between Peace
Walker and phantom pain this is bridge a
chokehold someone you could choke him
out you can use them as a human shield
you can stab when you'll altom utley
have three options right out the gate
you can interrogate him for information
you can knock him out just by squeezing
their neck or you can stab them and kill
him you grab guys by the head you
faceplant am I like the CQC it's like
every Metal Gear Solid game has been
taken into account to create this game
which plays about as well as the Metal
Gear Solid games [ __ ] what I really like
is when you get seen it does that bram
and everything slows down you have a
couple seconds it's all jungle war walls
gonna lock under their head and shoot
them a little of
I like that I like the fact that when I
get seen it slows me down because you're
supposed to be able to do that [ __ ]
because you're not actually a marine or
a special operative in real life we're
just gamers big boss though is like the
greatest military soldier of all time so
yeah that's how he sees he's like Oh
reflexes cuz I'm big boss kind of makes
him superhuman and cool and I like the
fact that he's superhuman it cool and
Kiefer Sutherland as big boss's voice I
love the [ __ ] out of it it's initially
when I heard him I'm like this Kiefer
Sutherland it's just a weird it's
different that's the second audio
recording Tabas the prelude to this game
you're like now I fall right into it why
I didn't even realize my brain was doing
this until I heard Kiefer Sutherland
voice big boss in this game and Kiefer
Sutherland voicing him makes him such a
different character than Solid Snake
I've always known they're different
characters I get that I know David
Hayter will always be Solid Snake and
for a lot of people big box a Solid
Snake and Big Boss are two completely
different people but when they're voiced
by the same guy it's hard to separate
their ideology hearing Kiefer Sutherland
voice big boss makes them feel like
completely separate characters he's
supposed to feel that way big boss I'll
say so I feel like I don't think Solid
Snake would handle a situation like that
I love Kiefer Sutherland as big boss
anytime he's like I'm like David from
Lost Boys later and the graphics are
really [ __ ] good we should talk about
that [ __ ] holy crap the graphics in
ground zeroes is one of those things
where you play it you're like I've never
seen a video game look this good Metal
Gear Solid on the ps4 completely
validates buying a ps4 if nothing else
comes out for it except phantom pain
when it comes out you'd be like that's
fine I have phantom pain this game looks
so good the gameplay is so solid
the bummer is you don't walk away from
Ground zeroes feeling fulfill it's not
like ah cool that section is like a
small game now we'll move on to the next
game it leaves on such a cliffhanger
you're like I just want to watch a
couple more minutes just a couple of no
all right whatever man the bummer is it
would have been great if the Ground
zeroes segment was packed into the
phantom pain as part of a game the [ __ ]
thing is the game of game making is we
live in a world of DLC and don't blame
Hideo Kojima or game makers for this at
all I don't think it's their call I
think it's honestly as simple as the
studio's like you want us to distribute
that game awesome you have hopes and
dreams I get that you want your story
out there we get that all right well
you're gonna have to make DLC and so
they have to play the game and make DLC
now here's where the dividing factor
30 bucks for this game yeah you can
argue other games that are 30 bucks or
about two hours long so it's no
different but it's all about what you do
with the time given to you in the game
but you also can't help but compare this
game to other Metal Gear Solid games
like Peace Walker you have like 120
missions for probably about 30 bucks
ground zeroes you have five for about 30
bucks granted the map in this game is
really huge there's a lot you can do you
can come this thing over and you're like
I just I seen you [ __ ] all the time it's
just so big it's so vast and so alive
this demo if I'm gonna call it a demo
will keep you entertained for a long
time so if you're not a Metal Gear Solid
fan if you haven't jumped on the Metal
Gear Solid train yet I would say there
are other things out there of Metal Gear
Solid quality that you can get for
around 30 bucks that you should probably
get before this you want this one game
that's short you want the middle of your
sell at HD collection it's three games
it's a lot longer I'd say get that first
and that for you guys who were not Metal
Gear Solid fans I would say this game is
worth buying at sale price fact is if
you're a Metal Gear Solid fan you've
already got in this game there's nothing
I can tell you that you don't already
know this game looks great it plays
great it's well acted by the actors
there's a lot of stuff to do you're
playing it right now you're gonna be
playing it for many many weeks to come
short yeah sweet oh yeah and like I said
you've paid more for less for my fellow
Metal Gear Solid fans out there I will
say Metal Gear Solid 5 Ground zeroes is
worth buying at full price thirty bucks
is steep but I don't have any regrets
about it
fact is you're gonna play it for a lot
longer than a couple hours if you just
line up gameplay it's not two hours long
it's a lot of hours long for some Metal
Gear Solid 5 Ground zeroes have you
played it what did you think about it
what system did you get it on or are you
gonna wait till it drops in prize or
just wait for phantom pain whatever you
think about any of it comment below let
me know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
[Music]